we will now use counting to solve a
simple probabilistic problem we have in
our hands
an ordinary six-sided die which we're
going to roll six times
so this is our probabilistic experiment
and we're interested in the probability
of a certain event the event that the
six rolls result in different numbers so
let us give a name to that event and
call it event a so we wish to calculate
the probability of this event but before
we can even get started answering this
question we need a probabilistic model
we need to make some assumptions and the
assumption that we are going to make is
that all outcomes of this experiment are
equally likely this is going to place us
within a discrete uniform probabilistic
model so that we can calculate
probabilities by Counting in particular
as we discussed earlier in this lecture
the probability of an event a is going
to be the number of elements of the set
a the number of outcomes that make event
a occur divided by the total number of
possible outcomes which is the number of
elements in our sample space so let us
start with a denominator and let us look
at the typical outcomes of this
experiment a typical outcome is
something like something like this
sequence two three four three six two
that's one possible outcome how many
outcomes of this kind are there well we
have six choices for the result of the
first roll six choices for the result of
the second roll and so on and since we
have a total of six rolls this means
that there is a total of six to the
sixth power possible outcomes according
to the counting principle
and by the way since we have so many
possible outcomes and we assume that
they're equally likely the probability
of each one of them would be 1 over 6 to
the sixth incidentally that's the same
number the same answer you would get if
you were to assume instead of assuming
directly that all outcomes are equally
likely to just assume that the different
roles are roles of a fair six-sided die
so each so the probability of getting a
2 is 1/6 and also that the different
roles are independent of each other
so in that case the probability let's
say of this particular sequence would be
the probability of obtaining a 2 which
is 1/6 times the probability that we get
a 3 at the next role which is 1/6 times
1/6 times 1/6 and so on and we get the
same answer 1 over 6 to the 6 so we see
that this assumption of all equal all
outcomes being equally likely has an
alternative interpretation in terms of
having a fair die which is rolled
independently 6 times now let us look at
the event of interest a what is a
typical element of a the typical element
of a is a sequence of 6 rolls in which
no number gets repeated so for example
it could be a roll like a sequence of
results of this kind for each number
appears just once so all the numbers
appear exactly once
in this sequence so what we need here is
basically to have a permutation of the
numbers 1 up to 6 so these six numbers
have to appear in an arbitrary order in
how many ways can we order six elements
then this is the number of permutations
of a set of six elements and as we
discussed earlier this is equal to 6
factorial so we have now counted the
number of outcomes that make event a
happen which is 6 factorial and by
calculating this ratio we
have obtained the probability of the
desire event you can now pause and try
to solve a problem of a similar kind